der mietwahnsinn in Deutschland wird
immer krasser
hier in Köln haben wir ein besonders
erschreckendes Inserat gefunden der
vermietet jemand seinen Balkon für 720
Euro ja den mietai den wollen wir doch
mal persönlich kennenlernen würde ich
sagen
schönen guten Tag sie vermieten also ein
Zelt auf ihrem Balkon und scheiße
ey jetzt macht die Kamera auf hey hey
[Musik]
besonders in deutschen Städten ist die
Wohnungsnot groß nee falsch sie war groß
denn schon vor ein paar Monaten hat die
Ampel das Problem ja gelöst einfach aus
Land ziehen eine bahnbrechende Idee ja
komm komm komm also da kann die Bahn
jetzt wirklich nichts hören
jetzt sei nicht so pessimistisch um den
Vorschlag umzusetzen hat die Ampel
immerhin ihre besten Männer nach Berlin
geschickt warum wurden sie nicht auf dem
Land weil ich davon weggezogen
was kein Mensch warum was war da los
drei Kilometer zum Bäcker 10 Kilometer
zum Arzt und und und das Land immer
solches bietet nichts aber nicht viel
die schönen Tierchen Schäfchen
Schweinchen
egal hauptsache sie machen Ihre Wohnung
in Berlin frei ja hauptsache weg ich
würde jetzt in die Lausitz ziehen ihr
könnt gerne meine Enkelkinder ja nicht
sehen ah Enkelkinder die Planen doch
auch nur rum und Nerven oder
aber verspricht nicht die Regierung Weg
ja irgendwie mehr Wohnungen aber das ist
die neue Idee der Regierung
aber da ist wahrscheinlich auch noch
nicht alles so doch super erstmal
hinziehen dann kann man immer gucken
aber was vermissen sie denn auf dem Land
und Ausland ja wunderbar aber dann
brauche ich ein zweites Auto sie können
ja nicht mit dem öffentlichen heutzutage
ich meine in Berlin fährt hier auch
ständig nicht aber wie soll ich zur
Arbeit kommen ja so weit haben wir jetzt
nicht nachgedacht ne wir haben
eigentlich gar nicht nachgedacht wir
haben erst wir haben einfach das ist
doch eine super Idee sie aufs Land das
wird schon gut gehen aber jetzt so im
Nachhinein war totaler Schwachsinn wenn
sie mir die Miete zahlen dann gehe ich
gerne auf Stand oder wenn sie mir auch
einen Job versoffen was können sie denn
ich kann Rettungsdienst
ja das wird das ist nicht so schlecht ja
für Thüringen reichts der Landarzt ja da
ist er
also sie sieht aufs Land ne haben wir so
verstanden Hand drauf alles klar
wieder hat die Ampel das Leben in Berlin
ein Stück besser gemacht
[Musik]
hallo sie ja sie sie sind ein absoluter
Glückspilz ich ja sie denn sie haben ein
sogenanntes Zuhause das kann nicht jeder
von sich behaupten denn aktuell fehlen
in Deutschland 700.000 Wohnungen aber
bevor das hier zu deprimieren wird
kennen sie schon das neue
Comedy-Programm von Olaf Scholz da
erzählt er sich selbst Witze die Zahl
der neuen Wohnungen geht immer weiter
zurück und trotzdem tut er Olaf durchs
Land und erzählt diesen Bruder die
Bundesregierung hat sich das Ziel
gesetzt jährlich 400.000 Wohnungen zu
bauen und den 400.000
Wohnungen die wir pro Jahr errichten
wollen damit es 400.000 Wohnungen pro
Jahr gibt
sage ich ja noch schlimmer ist es bei
Sozialwohnungen Anspruch auf eine haben
nämlich inzwischen 11 Millionen Miete
Haushalte wir haben aber nur noch 1,1
Millionen aber es besteht immer ein
Hoffnung wir haben eine
wohnungsministerin die sich mit dem
Thema auskennt für viele Menschen ist
ihre Wohnung auch ihr zu Hause
da das Bundesbauministerium aktuell mit
Asbest verseucht ist haben wir ganz
Potsdam abgeklingelt bis uns
irgendjemand in seinen Garten gelassen
hat und dorthin haben wir sie dann
eingeladen klarer Witz schön dass Sie da
sind sie kennen das Haus es gibt erstmal
eine Vorstellungsrunde es wäre nett wenn
sie in die Kamera schauen
heute zu Gast Clara Gallwitz sie sagt
über sich ich bin das Gesicht zur
aktuellen Baukrise und das fühlt sich
nicht schön an sind Sie zufrieden mit
den Zitate wie sie ausgesucht haben
ist leider zutreffend die Baubranche hat
eine schwierige Zeit okay da geht die
Vorstellungsrunde weiter wieder in die
Kamera schauen bekannt wurde Klara
geibels 2019 da wollte sie mit Olaf
Scholz zusammen SPD-Chef werden 2021
wurde sie dann Ministerin für Wohnstadt
Entwicklung und Bauwesen man kann also
sagen Olaf Scholz nimmt sich für die
komplett hoffnungslosen Projekte
ich bin mal gespannt was als nächstes
kommt was macht der Mann der mit ihnen
müssen sie weinen nein nein ich habe
eine kleine Spinne okay okay das Thema
Bauen Wohnen ist ja ein bisschen trocken
deswegen haben wir uns gedacht
dass wir heute ein bisschen spielen und
zwar
wir wollen halt äh bauen damit
wenigstens in dieser Legislatur ein Haus
gebaut wird ich fürchte aber das würde
nicht in die Statistiken also das wäre
keine große Hilfe ja aber für das Bild
ist doch gut wenigstens ein Haus wird
fertig also wir versuchen es mal ich
würde sagen
klares Traumhaus heißt es auch deshalb
weil im Gegensatz zu ihrem Ministerium
ist es nicht mit Asbest verseucht
richtig laut
ehrlich gesagt als ich das erste Mal im
Bauministerium bin war ich ziemlich
erschrocken weil das ist so ziemlich das
ranzigste Ministerium von allen
was auch so ein bisschen zeigt dass wir
auch Politik in der Vergangenheit
wirklich gerade große Stellenwert hatte
also man hat sich nicht viel Mühe
gemacht der Geld ins Bauministerium zu
investieren
ja das Problem beim Bau des wenn man
jahrelang was falsch gemacht hat braucht
man auch ziemlich lange damit die andere
Richtung wieder eingeschlagen wird aber
400.000 Wohnungen pro Jahr ist halt
nicht geklappt wenn Sie das gesteckte
Ziel sowieso nicht erreichen werden
warum nennen sie da nicht eine Zahl die
noch viel imposanter ist und sie sagen
wir bauen pro Jahr 1 Millionen Wohnung
das klingt ja erstmal viel besser
also ehrlich gesagt das was wir jetzt
machen das sind unterschiedliche
Maßnahmen damit möglichst viel gebaut
werden kann allerdings können wir
natürlich auch den Zinssprung nicht
weghexen sollte man da nicht lieber
realistisch sein und das wäre dann ihrer
Meinung nach naja nächstes Jahr ist ja
die Prognose sogar nur ich glaube
177000 im schlechtesten Fall also auf
diese Prognosen dann muss man ein
bisschen mit Vorsicht reagieren aber die
Lage ist ja aktuell schon dramatisch
muss man sagen deswegen ja 700.000
Wohnungen 11 Millionen Haushalte hätten
Anspruch auf eine Sozialwohnung wir
haben nur 1,1 Millionen müssen sie denn
nicht eigentlich auch aus eigenem
Interesse viel mehr Sozialwohnungen
bauen ich meine in zwei Jahren sind sie
arbeitslos
verstehen Sie die Wahl
ja glückwunsch
das Fundament steht bereits doch werden
die drei es schaffen klares Traumhaus
fertig zu bauen bleiben Sie dran
auf geht's nach München hier hat das
Land Bayern 2013 gemeinnützige Wohnungen
an private Investoren verkauft und jetzt
jetzt kauft die Stadt München viele der
Wohnung für fast das Vierfache wieder
zurück auch das aber nett von der Stadt
München grund genug für uns der Stadt
ein weiteres touristisches Highlight zu
beschehen die wohnen Horror Picture Show
erste Station ein Mietshaus das in den
letzten Jahren mehrfach gewinnbringend
verkauft wurde und fühlt sich das geil
an so einem Spekulationsobjekt zu sein
also unmittelbar nicht unbedingt glaube
ich also ich würde gerne doch verzichten
können also der erste Verkaufspreis lag
wohl so ca bei 10 bis 12 Millionen und
jetzt steht es auf der Seite
immobilieninvest von der Frau Penner für
32 Millionen 33 Millionen der taxiert
der Wert wahrscheinlich nach Sanierung
ich weiß es nicht keine Ahnung 32
Millionen Haus was wollen Sie denn noch
einfach mal wieder Ruhe keine Baustelle
eine normale Miete genau und jetzt sind
wir im Eigentum eines Ehepaars den Herrn
Menschen und die wollen das ganze Haus
sanieren und wollen uns eigentlich auch
wenn Sie das natürlich nie so ausdrücken
würden gerne aus dem Haus raus haben
damit es leichter wird und haben dann
einfach angekündigt dass die ganzen
Umstände sehr anstrengend werden dass
man nicht darin leben kann in der Zeit
wo sie umbauen ja dass man also bitte
gehen Sie bitte gehen
natürlich in seinem Leben vielleicht
andere Sachen machen als ich nur um die
Sicherung des eigenen Wohnraums kümmern
ja ich kann schon verstehen
[Musik]
vielen Dank ja war schön mal ihren
Horror zu sehen
habt Spaß gemacht hat einen schönen Tag
sage
20 Jahre wohnen die jetzt schon hier ne
krass diese Mietnomaden oder man kriegt
sie einfach nicht raus
und weiter geht's auf der wohnen Horror
Picture Show ein paar Straßen weiter
kämpft diese Hausgemeinschaft gegen den
Verkauf Ihres Hauses noch lacht dieses
bezaubernde Baby denn es hat das Wort
luxusanierung noch nie gehört viele
Hausbesitzer Erben ihr Haus einfach
warum machen sie das nicht so es ist
doch so einfach es ist doch so einfach
ganz einfach
ist es aber nicht stattdessen versucht
man es jetzt mit Crowdfunding
Privatpersonen die uns einen sogenannten
Direktkredit geben das heißt wir umgehen
die Bank bei der Sache nicht so
eindringlich an
der Grund warum wir hier sind jetzt
ergibt alles einen Sinn wenn sie jetzt
1000 € übrig haben ne sagen die brauche
ich jetzt gerade nicht oder in den
nächsten 5 Jahren
wo könnte ich denn jetzt die größere
Rendite machen wenn ich bei Ihnen direkt
investiere oder wenn ich das Haus kaufe
kernsaniere und dann auf dem freien Tag
als Luxuswohnung ich hab ja nur
theoretisch ekelhaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
letzte Station ein ganz besonderer
Horror studentisches Wohnen Diese
Wohnheime stehen seit zwei Jahren wegen
fehlendem Brandschutz leer zum Glück
wird jetzt schnell gehandelt schon 2028
sollen die Häuser sein jetzt sein das
muss dieses deutschlandtempo sein von
dem man immer so viel hört
[Musik]
das muss ich sagen ist echt Horror hier
das ist ja wie im Film was ist denn hier
los bzw was ist hier nicht los hier ist
ungefähr
1000 Wohnungen Leerstand 1000 Wohnungen
Lehrstunde ungefähr aber ich meine 1000
Wohnplätze zum Glück ist der Münchner
mietmagier entspannt ne das ist ja nicht
so schlimm wenn da welche Abfahrt oder
ihr habt die Zeit vor allem ist ja das
interessante auch dass sich glaube ich
seit den 90ern die Zahlen der Studenten
hier verdoppelt haben in München aber
die Zahl der Wohnheimplätze ist gleich
geblieben weißt du was ich aber nicht
mehr nicht nur verdoppelt hat sondern
sehr viel verfehlt hat die Warteliste
vom Studierendenwerk da sind inzwischen
15.000 Studierende drauf nur für München
und deutschlandweit im Vergleich dazu
warten 35.000 Studierende auf den äh
studiowohnheim also fast die Hälfte von
allen in Deutschland warten in
Studierenden warten in München und das
was wir hier eigentlich um uns sehen das
ist eigentlich nur sehr konzentriert das
Problem weil solche Wohnheime die
einfach leer stehen gibt es in München
auch noch anders wo müssen wir halt mal
überlegen
bleibt und danach schlaft muss auch mal
Abstriche machen fürs studieren hier ist
ja oder hier ist doch schön ist doch
jetzt gerade im Sommer so ein bisschen
camping ist ja irgendwie auch romantisch
oder so also letztendlich wird es auch
passieren also ich glaube Anfang des
Semesters gibt es da geplante Aktionen
wo vor der Uni gekämpft nach rechts
wie aus einem Gag ernst wird in der EU
leben weniger als 30 Prozent der
Haushalte zur Miete in Deutschland sind
es allerdings 54% bei der eigenheimquote
liegen wir EU weit auf dem letzten Platz
weshalb z.B viele Franzosen innerlich
fundierte Kritik äußern ich bin an die
deutsche gerade deswegen Treffen zu
steigenden Mieten besonders hart aber zu
den Fakten
263.000 Menschen haben aktuell keine
Wohnung allein in Berlin sind die
angebotsmilben im letzten Jahr noch um
20% gestiegen und über 3 Millionen
Menschen geben 40% oder mehr ihres
Einkommens für Mieter aus da stellt sich
doch wirklich langsam die Frage
Konsequenz aus dem vorgelegten Zahlen
keine völlig richtig denn Linden aus
Parteifreund und Justizminister Marco
Buschmann blockiert aktuell die
Verlängerung der mietpreisbremse dass
die Mieten in angespannten Märkten
innerhalb von drei Jahren nur noch um
11% steigen dürfen und die Einführung
eines qualifizierten Mietspiegels in
allen Großstädten um noch
Verhandlungsmasse gegenüber SPD und
Grünen zu haben naja immerhin hat der
Marco dann Zeit für die wichtigen Dinge
z.B jeden Tag das exakt gleiches selfie
bei Instagram zu posten oder die
Mietpreise sollen ja auch runtergehen
das hat die Ampel sicher durchaus
vorgenommen aber jetzt zumindest für
dieses Haus haben wir eine schlechte
Nachricht jemand kauft das Haus dieser
Typ hier und der blockiert einfach mal
eben für dieses Haus eine Verlängerung
der mietpreisbremse der blockiert dass
die kappungsgrenzen gesenkt werden
der Marco
also persönlich verstehen wir uns sehr
gut aber inhaltlich trennen uns
natürlich einiges aber stimmt das das
Marco Buschmann die vereinbarten Gesetze
wirklich einfach nur als
Verhandlungsmasse blockiert
ich würde da jetzt nicht laut
widersprechen das ist doch für die
Politik ein total verheerendes Bild was
da entsteht meine Koalition sagt gerade
in so einem angespannten Mieter was wir
verlängern nicht die mietpreisbremse
weil erstmal machst du das und das was
ist das für eine Verständnis von Politik
politik ist immer ein
Aushandlungsprozess von sehr
unterschiedlichen Sachen
also wie gesagt ich würde mich freuen
wenn Marco Buschmann bald dieses Gesetz
vorliegt ich habe gelesen im Oktober
letzten Jahres hat er schon mit
Hochdruck daran gearbeitet
tja also richtig kompliziert ist es
nicht deswegen hoffe ich dass er bald
fertig ist wenn er mit so hohem Druck
dran arbeitet sie können den jetzt
einfach wegschmeißen einfach aus dem
Haus nehmen und weg dann ist er nicht
mehr da
ich fürchte das funktioniert
zum ersten mal was zu sagen jetzt hier
schmeißen sie ihn weg ich würde das
generell nicht empfehlen dass man seine
Probleme verdrängt man muss sich schon
an einen Tisch setzen und nach einer
Lösung suchen während die einen streiten
wird anderswo längst gebaut in einer
Heidelberger WG kam Studenten 2013 ein
absurder Gedanke
das Problem ist hier in Heidelberg wie
in vielen anderen Städten das ist
einfach nicht genug Wohnraum gibt das
ist nicht nur ein reinen staatliches
sondern auch natürlich ein kommunales
Problem da kann man eben die Idee auf
dass wir das doch selber angehen könnten
und uns ihr eben unser eigenes Wohnheim
bauen und ja das haben wir gemacht wie
viel Geld musst du dir denn aufbringen
für den ganzen Bau also insgesamt nur
für den Neubau hier mit Grundstück und
Bau und etc alles sind es 21 Millionen
Euro das ganze gekostet haben finanziert
eben über einen großen Kredit aber auch
Überforderungen und eben vor allem über
die Direktkredit also über 600 Leute die
uns wirklich ein ganz ganz kleinen
Betrag irgendwie zur Verfügung gestellt
haben den wir auch irgendwann
zurückzahlen werden wenn die Leute
wieder zurück haben wollen ähm also
quasi auch so ein Kraut basierten System
mehr oder weniger wie ist denn das wenn
ich jetzt hier im Zimmer mieten würde
also ich kann nicht keine Sorge ich habe
in kein Langzeitstudent aber wie würde
das dann aussehen und wie teuer ist das
vor allem also momentan sind wir bei
einer Miete von ich meine 345
du würdest dich einfach auf das Thema
bewerben dann gibt es auswahltage wir
haben Kriterien festgelegt nach denen
wir objektiv die die Menschen die
einzigen auswählen schlecht für dich
wusste es gibt einen Haken
könnten Fabian und ich auch anpacken
hier jetzt konkret ein bisschen
mithelfen
stimmt die sind noch drüben
im Bundestag aber
ich packe
[Musik]
so Kinder erstmal Frühstück
sorry ich bin heute zuständig für den
Bau hier ich muss das Unterschreiben
wie findet ihr das das hier hier selber
so anpacken müsst weil es ja der Staat
offensichtlich nicht hinkrieg genügend
Wohnraum zu schaffen für Auszubildende
Studenten
also ist zum einen scheiße dass es so
ist also ich mein hallo wir hätten auch
besseres zu tun und heute schleppen wir
so ein paar Platten
an die Stelle wo sie hingehören weil wir
damit Kosten sparen und damit am Ende
das Haus nicht so viel kostet und die
Mieten günstiger sind dann los komm
kinderplatten
komm komm komm
[Musik]
rein in die Masse Jungs los los geht's
noch eine Nachtschicht denn wir reißen
Mauern nein wie 1900 80
arbeiten
richtig am Bau arbeiten
okay ich lass jetzt los den Knopf ne
[Applaus]
ja nicht klatschen arbeiten hier
rumstehen kann ich auch ich mache das
mit dem Knopf weiter seid das wirklich
nur hier also Amateur oder gibt's auch
Profis die euch helfen also wer hat das
Gerüst gebaut zum Beispiel das haben
tatsächlich externe Handwerksfirmen okay
das beruhigt mich nein weil manche Dinge
sollten vielleicht Profis machen auch
oder wie lange glaubt ihr müsst ihr noch
arbeiten bis es fertig wird
das Haus hier wird zum herbstfertig das
wird schon zum herbstfertig und da
drüben sind wir ja schon angezogen und
wenn man sich immer umguckt in diesem
ganzen konversionsgebiet nichts ist
fertig nur das Projekt was hier Azubis
und Studis machen die ja eigentlich noch
eine anderen Job nebenher haben
warum ist das so warum seid ihr
schneller wir haben sehr viel Ehrgeiz
Lutz an Fabian bin immer noch auf dem
Bau habe die Lage voll im Griff wie
sieht's aus dem Bundestag
ich bin diesmal nicht alleine im
Bundestag unterwegs denn ich helfe einem
Freund und es ist nicht Lust
[Musik]
können Sie sich vorstellen in ihrer
Wohnung hier in Berlin einen Studenten
aufzunehmen der sucht eine Wohnung ist
der Sinn nein
kannst du einfach Nein viele Abgeordnete
haben ja auch ein Wohnsitz in Berlin und
wir wollen nicht nur reden ne wir wollen
noch mal ein Zeichen setzen wären Sie
bereit einen Berliner Studenten auf
Wohnungssuche bei sich einziehen zu
lassen naja ich kenn ihn jetzt doch
nicht aber es kommt
hallo Finn schön Dich kennenzulernen und
er hat nur positive Eigenschaften er ist
zum Beispiel nicht in der CDU sie haben
doch auch eine Berliner Wohnung können
sie nicht vielleicht eine WG gründen ihn
aufnehmen
Putzplan
einmal den ich geschrieben habe
sie studieren was Sozialwissenschaften 9
Semester ja ist doch schön also zur
Hälfte geschafft
insofern ja keine vor mir auch nichts
ordentliches gemacht wenn Sie ihn nicht
aufnehmen wollen könnten Sie stattdessen
auch das BAföG so erhöhen dass es für
eine durchschnittliche Wohnung in Berlin
reicht da wäre ich auch sehr dafür ich
weiß nicht vorher ist hier irgendwo
Lindner rumgesprungen wir fangen Sie
doch mal den nicht da ist der
Finanzminister sie haben den besseren
Kontakt wenn ich ehrlich bin äh wir
müssen diese Knoten alle lösen die wir
da so miteinander haben
irgendwie auch nicht so optimistisch
doch
einmal in die Kamera sagen wir werden
das schaffen wir kriegen das alles hin
wir sind ein bisschen schrill ein
bisschen bunt ein bisschen klopft im
Umgang miteinander
aber wir liefern ja das wird mir auch
noch liefern
sie sollten jetzt nicht ironisch werden
ne
okay
welche Bücher er hat Schwangerschaft und
Geburt
Schwangerschaft und Geburt okay das
passt zu Ihnen beiden nicht aber warum
nicht schwere Geburten passen immerhin
zum heizungsgesetz ne
[Gelächter]
gut die Ampel hilft meinem Kumpel schon
mal nicht dann müssen wir jetzt einfach
mal so ein bisschen denken
beim Thema Wohnungsnot ist ein
Lösungsansatz natürlich auch das
generationsübergreifende wohnen zum
Beispiel ein junger Student zusammen mit
einem Senioren okay also ich finde
Wohnungsnot ist ein Thema übrigens gibt
es aber nicht nur Studienorte in den
Hauptstädten sondern auch irgendwie
etwas weiter draußen das ist manchmal
noch besser mit dem Finden einer Wohnung
er bringt auch Cannabis mit in die WG
ist das ein Angebot nee das ist kein
Angebot und ich würde sagen wer auch gut
wenn man sich vielleicht noch mehr auf
die Studieninhalte und weniger auf
Cannabis konzentriert das würde der
Volkswirtschaft auch helfen aber da
drücke ich die Daumen geschafft er will
auch gar nicht mehr bei ihnen irgendwo
und dann passiert das unglaubliche nach
stundenlanger Überzeugungsarbeit erbarmt
sich Paul ziemiak von der CDU und nimmt
den Berliner Studenten auf ja und das
ist das erste Mal dass hier ein
CDU-Politiker nach 16 Jahren Versagens
in der Wohnungspolitik Mann aktives
Zeichen das toll wirklich in die Handeln
ja
ich glaube den Wohnungsschlüssel habe
ich die müssen sie sich im Büro holen ja
dann kommen wir später vorbei und dann
machen wir das und dann gehen wir
zusammen in die Wohnung
sagen können also ich würde euch dann
auch besuchen wenn du bei Paul
unterkommst aber ich würde mir
mitbringen aber kann er bis nicht also
das sollten mal irgendwie so kiffen mit
Paul ziemiak und Philipp glaube jetzt
konzentriert er sich wirklich lieber auf
Studio um das ist
Entscheidung ja es gibt sie noch wenn
man ein bisschen sucht auch in
Deutschland doch sie sind selten
geworden Baustellen für Wohnungen denn
allein zwischen 2007 und 2017 sind die
Baukosten um 33% gestiegen oben drauf
kommen jetzt noch Inflation teureres
Material und hohe Energiekosten bauen
lohnt sich nicht mehr kein Wunder dass
im ersten Halbjahr die Baugenehmigungen
für Wohnungen im Vergleich zum
Vorjahreszeitraum um 27 % zurückgegangen
sind in manchen Bauämtern stellt man
sich schon die bange Frage
wofür brauchen wir eigentlich ein
Faxgerät gut bauen ist in Deutschland
zwar teuer aber dafür immerhin
kompliziert
1990 gab es in Deutschland nur
lächerliche 5000 Bauvorschriften aber
keine Sorge das hat sich geändert
inzwischen haben wir 20.000
Bauvorschriften und das ist noch nicht
alles stimmt denn zusätzlich haben wir
nicht nur zwei oder vier nein wir haben
16 verschiedene Landesbauordnung
oben drauf kommt wie überall der
Fachkräftemangel das ist in diesem Fall
besonders lustig denn wissen Sie was
internationale Fachkräfte an Deutschland
besonders stört 58 Prozent der Befragten
hatten Probleme hier eine Wohnung zu
finden
[Musik]
Dortmund hier gibt es noch echte
Malocher warum ich dann hier bin weiß
ich zwar auch nicht aber auf dem Bau
können sie ja heutzutage jeden
gebrauchen also Lewski kann losgehen
gebaut werden oder das ist wohl wahr ja
das ist wunderbar und wie läuft's hier
gerade aktuell zum Glück jetzt
mittlerweile gut hat ja auch nur knapp
14 Jahre gedauert bis losgehen 14 Jahre
was müsste man in ihrer Meinung nach
ändern damit das besser ist die
regulieren Wurzel allen Übels ist
eigentlich viel zu viele Regeln wir
schützen uns vor allem möglichen
Lärmschutz Schallschutz Brandschutz
schützen schützen nur bis wir dann
abgeprüft haben und gestempelt haben und
festgestellt haben dass wir genügend
geschützt sind die Prozesse dauern halt
ziemlich lange
ich finde die Baustelle ja ganz gut was
ich allerdings noch besser finde wäre
wenn man diese hässliche komische Wand
hier abreißen würde was soll das die
schützt die Menschen von nicht
vorhandenem lärmen des benachbarten
Gewerbegebiets ach die haben sie erst
gebaut oder was natürlich für knappe 7
Millionen Euro haben wir hier ein
Kilometer Wand hingestellt
sie haben 1 km Wand hier hingestellt wir
7 Millionen Euro alles gut bei ihm oder
ja
warum was soll das Lärmschutz ist was
ganz wichtiges also gesunde
Wohnverhältnisse heißen in der Nacht hat
man einen halben Meter vorm Fenster
draußen nicht mehr als 45 DBA
Schalldruck oder darf man haben so
wenn es Gewerbe Lärm ist wenn es jetzt
zum Beispiel Straßenverkehrslärm wäre
dürften 55 dB sein
da jetzt die Laster von der öffentlichen
Straße hier auf dem privates Grundstück
fahren lassen Gewerbegrundstück ist
werden sie in dem Moment wo sie über die
Grenze fahren ungesund weil dann werden
sie Gewerbe lernen um die Dimension mal
zu verstehen 70 Quadratmeter Wohnung
wird durch das Ding bei einer sehr
konservativen Verzinsung 28 € teurer
jeden Monat ein Leben lang
[Applaus]
wunderbare Vokabeln im deutschen
Bauwesen
doppelkopfbolzenhohl zum
talstaubmaschinen habe ich bei meiner
letzten werksversicherung weiß ich doch
nicht sagen
und haben sie das mit dem Graffiti
gemacht dass das schöner aussieht nein
die Künstler habe ich engagiert die
waren teuer weil das deswegen ist es so
schön geworden
[Musik]
und es begab sich zu einer Zeit als der
Bebauungsplan noch in Bearbeitung war
kam ein Gutachter und sollte feststellen
wie laut der Lernenden ist jetzt von den
Bananen ja genau und dann hat er sich
mit seinem Campingstuhl neben den unter
dem Baum gesetzt in der Nacht und
unseren Mikro in die Luft gehalten ja
und sein Messgerät
um 5:34 Uhr hat er ein heftigen
Ausschlag ist aber was passiert ist so
ein bananenlaster gekommen Lösung
jetzt ernsthaft ja natürlich ernsthaft
also meine Fantasie reicht nicht um mir
solche Geschichten einfallen zu lassen
das ist schon echt passiert
[Musik]
jetzt gucken wir uns mal Klimaschutz
live an nawärme aus fernwärme ist das
gut das ist gut
weil ich muss nicht in jedem Haus die
Wärmeerzeuger haben sondern ich ziehe
alle über diesen Schlauch beliefert das
ist wirklich schön das ist wirklich gut
das Stein war raus dass irritiert mich
gut ist das braucht man den Beitrag
Bauen und Wohnen ist eigentlich
Länderkompetenz und am Ende entscheidet
die Kommune das heißt also 16
Landesbauordnung geht ja nur
einigermaßen aber wir haben wenn ich bei
Wikipedia richtig gelesen habe 10.000
960 Städte und Gemeinden in Deutschland
und die haben die Planungshoheit das
heißt also wenn jetzt zum Beispiel
serielles Baum ich erfinden super
günstiges Haus schnell und einfach zu
bauen preiswert herzustellen und würde
sagen dass damit überziehe ich jetzt die
ganze Republik und wird schnell
reiche Idee
auf diesem Grundstück darfst du 35 Grad
Dachneigung und drei Meter weiter
vielleicht 38 und den noch woanders 42
Grad das heißt also ich muss jetzt mal
das Dach Leute planen ja er Salewski ich
bin jetzt zu ihm gekommen habe gesagt
ich will bauen
das mache ich nicht so ist ja viel zu
kompliziert ich wünsche Ihnen aber viel
Glück Dankeschön kann ich gebrauchen
nichts wie weg hier ist der grauenhaft
also irgendwas machen wir hier
grundlegend falsch ich kriege gerade die
Nachricht wir müssen alles wieder
umbauen weil wir bauen ja nach der
Berliner Bauordnung und jetzt sind wir
in Brandenburg und das ist ja eine ganz
andere Sache weil da müssen ja die
Treppengeländer unterschiedlich hoch
sein
das heißt wir müssen also das komplett
noch mal abbauen lassen
bevor man anfängt zu bauen also man muss
gucken ob man das kann aber es ist nicht
ich meine das ist Luftlinie wie viel
Kilometer
ist der Aufbau des deutschen Staates wir
sind ein föderales Land es gibt doch
fragen die sind in Brandenburg total
wichtig also zum Beispiel wie gehe ich
mit mobilen Hühner stellen um dass wir
jetzt was was das Berliner
Landesparlament wahrscheinlich nicht so
treibt sie das also dann hat jedes Land
hat was zu sagen wenn die Gemeinden ja
auch noch da gibt's die Verordnung da
gibt's die Norm also ich meine so kommen
wir natürlich auch nicht brennt ja jetzt
auch nicht anders so schön in Hessen
also in Bayern Brand ist ja genau gleich
die Brandschutzordnung sind auch überall
verschieden also es ist nicht nervig
also das ist der Aufbau so wie unsere
Bundesrepublik funktioniert und das oder
auch für mich vielleicht ja aber
vielleicht ist das auch Teil des
Problems jetzt wollen sie ja bis Ende
des Jahres in digitalen Bauantrag
einführen da haben wir eigentlich nur
eine Frage zu den gibt es noch nicht den
digitalen Bauantrag das ist genau jetzt
auch wieder die Frage des Föderalismus
wir entwickeln nicht den digitalen
Bauantrag sondern wir geben mehr
Millionen an das Land
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern die das machen
das wird dann von den Bundesländern die
wollen übernommen das heißt es ja eine
super Nachricht dann haben wir endlich
16 Bundesländer die einen einheitlichen
digitalen Bauantrag haben ne nein so
wird es natürlich nicht sein weil ich
nicht wir sind im Föderalismus wofür
haben wir denn überhaupt eine
wohnungsministerium jetzt gegründet wenn
alle wichtige Entscheidung entweder bei
den Ländern liegen oder beim
Justizministerium ich habe ihn ja gerade
gesagt warum der Justizminister
zuständig ist Vertragsrecht ist
Vertragsrecht und deswegen kümmert er
sich darum was machen Sie den ganzen Tag
überhaupt
also wir setzen die Rahmenbedingungen
für das Bauen in Deutschland ja ich habe
ganz schlechte Nachrichten übrigens
gerade ja ähm wir müssen das komplette
Haus abreißen Robert Habeck ist nicht
einverstanden weil es hat keine
Wärmepumpe und ist entspricht auch nicht
der Norm weil es viel zu schlecht
gedämmt ist es ist leider alles sinnlos
ein schönes Spiel ist das aber nicht
mehr
man ist das alles deprimierend lass uns
doch mal irgendwo hin wo es gut läuft
zum Beispiel in eine kleine Stadt in
Österreich namens Wien Fabian ich kann
leider nicht ich muss auch eine
Wohnungsbesichtigung okay dann fahre ich
halt allein das ist 60% der Wien und
Wienerinnen wohnen im geförderten also
über 400.000 Sozialwohnungen gibt es in
Wien richtige 420 mehr sich das mal
vorstellt in ganz Deutschland gibt es
nur noch 1,1 Millionen und Wien hat
400.000 Fehler ist in den meisten
Städten passiert dass sie dann nach dem
Zusammenbruch des Eisernen Vorhangs
Privatisierungswelle privatisiert haben
und deshalb bin ich nicht gemacht also
unser Erfolgsgeheimnis ist dass wir
nichts verkauft haben also eine
wien-situation
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich wollte dieses Gespräch ja eigentlich
auf Ibiza mit Ihnen führen aber ihr Büro
meinte irgendwie das ist ungeeignet für
politische Gespräche wirklich haben
ja schon unfassbare viele öffentliche
Wohnungen und ihr baut ja immer noch
weiter ist die Wiener Politik klüger
oder sind die anderen einfacher
mir setzen das Trinkgeld vor dass wir
stehen jetzt hier vor village im dritten
einem großen Entwicklungsgebiet 22
Hektar und insgesamt wie gesagt 1.900
Wohnungen mit Kindergärten
einkaufsstruktur Arbeitsmöglichkeiten
und das ganze in einem Gebiet das sehr
durchmischt ist ja Bürgermeister hat ja
gesagt es soll in Wien keine Bezirke
geben wo nur reiche leben
das haben wir in Deutschland zumindest
auch geschafft Gelsenkirchen zum
Beispiel was ist da passiert da wohnen
keine reichen okay da haben wir darauf
geachtet ich habe jetzt kein klares Bild
im Kopf wie sieht denn eine Wiener
Sozialwohnung aus bevor man darüber
reden schauen oder ja gerne
[Musik]
sie haben eine bezahlbare Wohnung in der
lebenswertesten Stadt der Welt ich habe
mir sie fröhlicher vorgestellt ja ich
tanzender soll ja gerne
ich habe eine Wohnung bis 60
Quadratmeter und Zahl 400 Euro 4 für 60
Quadratmeter seit wann wohnen Sie hier
seit 30 Jahren unser 30 nur 400 Euro
billiger angefangen hat dass billiger
angefangen
aber es ist nicht Ausbeutung von
Vermietern das ist egal
Meter so 90
sind bei uns in Österreich so ca 700 €.
das ist die Hälfte ja sie macht eine
maximal
[Musik]
und das hier ist jetzt wirklich eine
Sozialwohnung beeindruckend
[Musik]
doch auch in diesem Spezial bleiben wir
immer drei Fragen offen haben sie sowas
als Kind gemacht eigentlich Playmobil
Lego irgendwie sowas
war Lutz van der Horst den Studenten in
Heidelberg eine Hilfe okay
ich
achso andere Stock
Werk und wer hat Fabian und Lutz diese
WG in guter Lage vermietet wenn ich den
zwischen die Finger kriege
los endcard ja mach du mal ich komme
gleich was machst du denn ja ich messe
außer meine Couch hierhin passt ich will
dir vielleicht einziehen das ist ja eine
super Idee ich habe auch noch so eine
Ausziehcouch die könnte man hier
vielleicht okay das ist eine gute Idee
dann könnte man aber die Zuschauer die
gucken jetzt weiter Videos und klicken
auf die Links ja wir können einfach
klicken und wir können hier okay weil
wenn ich die Couch nämlich hier
hinstellen kannst du hier super so einen
kleinen könnte man auch noch und dann
wenn du den Fernseher warte mal
Fernseher wäre